[Musique]
je ne me rendrais pas je ne me retirerai
pas si tu ne compose je vois pas bien je
veux dire à pénélope que je laime son
médecin dans la nasse c'est pourquoi
j'ai adressé au président de la
république ma démission des élus et des
attachés parlementaires dans la tempête
d'une campagne où le discrédit jeté sur
la classe politique n'a jamais paru
aussi important
[Musique]
pour plus fort de la tourmente
médiatique dans un amphithéâtre de
l'université d'orléans
ils sont quelques-uns à attendre avec
impatience le sésame qui leur ouvrira
les portes d'une belle carrière car leur
ambition c'est de faire de la politique
en est un genre un regard neuf c'est à
dire qu'on n'est pas content on a des
affaires on n'a jamais eu encore
d'affaires on n'aura pas j'espère et
c'était vraiment dire la jeunesse
on veut apporter quelque chose de
nouveau on veut changer cette vieille
classe politique qui en place depuis des
années et qui est dans des affaires de
corruption ou dans des favoritismes si
on doit être opéré
c'est pour essayer de changer des choses
je dis pas radicalement parce que bien
entendu on peut pas changer ce système
et roland moreau - apporter sa petite
pierre à l'édifice auquel m le master
des métiers de l'accompagnement
politique une spécialité récente pour
former des professionnels dans un
secteur jusqu'à présent peu regardant
sur le cv ce sont des vrais métiers
contrairement à ce que l'actualité
récente aurait pu faire croire et donc
il faut une formation c'est comme pour
être prof avocats magistrats aux
médecins et donc on leur apprend à la
fois les bases du droit public
essentiellement de l'histoire politique
contemporaine et de la communication les
réseaux sociaux et à tous ceux dont les
professionnels de la politique ont
énormément besoin aujourd'hui pour
communiquer
[Musique]
quand il n'est pas sur les bancs de
l'université d'orléans
antoine 22 ans travaille en alternance à
paris
en face de l'assemblée nationale dans
les bureaux de la permanence de campagne
de nicolas dupont aignan la politique il
est tombé dedans en regardant l'émission
de laurent ruquier on n'est pas couché
j'ai eu le déclic avec un exe mots en
fait je trouvais qu'on n'entendait pas
une voix comme ça dans les grands médias
et ça m'a tout de suite plu et je me
suis intéressé après tout
à toutes ces pensées et puis j'ai
découvert d'autres auteurs comme sur
chevènement ou alors natacha polony
aussi ou fait qu'elle compte dans
l'équipe du patron de debout la france
antoine apprend la stratégie politique
je travaille sur l'argumentaire de
maquereau en fait un argumentaire qu'on
avait faits lorsqu'elle s'est présentée
candidat en décembre dernier et le blick
à soupe ram est enfin sorti donc du coup
on réactualise l'argumentaire pour
ensuite nicolas dupont aignan et des
arguments quand ce qu'on me demande ce
qui lui plaît pas chez événements
comprise
donc on a réutilisé les chiffres du csa
ouais c'est une personne mais le thème
dominant de la campagne c'est bien la
moralisation de la vie publique
la vraie question c'est ce qu'on dit
honnête on l'est pas on voulait faire dé
toutes les doigts de la terre il faut de
l'honnêteté et ça je crois que le
meilleur contrôle sur les partis
politiques qui doivent à un moment dire
toi tu as été condamné tu dégages ce qui
est intéressant c'est le temps d'antenne
frappé le temps de parole non france 3
en a remonté oui france 5 on est
toujours très bas mélenchon ce très
mauvais mélenchon de rançon c'est très
fatigué ce n'est pas que les français ne
sont complètement désintéressés des
politiques alors qu'ils adorent la
politique mais aujourd'hui on les a
complètement dégoûté avec les affaires
avec certains comportements d'élus je
pense qu'on peut changer les choses par
la poétique et voilà je veux servir
assemblée
changer la société par la politique
c'est aussi la motivation de thierry 32
ans un des trois assistants
parlementaires d'isabelle bruno député
ps de l'indre
ancien syndicaliste à l'unef et
formateur de métier il est arrivé à
l'assemblée nationale il y a cinq ans il
est aussi secrétaire général du syndicat
fo des assistants parlementaires et donc
un ardent défenseur de la profession si
vous allez sur le site de l'assemblée si
on présentait à des gens vous savez une
infinité de ressources
voyez les statistiques les statistiques
de l'assemblée sur la cession sur 2
septembre jusqu'à jusqu'à février
c'est dingue le nombre de textes c'est
dingue le nombre de questions écrites
ont été posées c'est dingue c'est ce
travail là il est des votes fou quoi et
en fait il ya une méconnaissance de
cette institution
alors quand on lui parle d'emplois
fictifs
il dégaine avec des arguments très
concret 4000 euros par mois vous rendez
compte c'est personnes un vin très peu
de personnes de mes collègues de mai
connect touche tous se sert là ça nous a
mis en colère çà nous aimions colère
collectivement
moi ça m'a mis en colère
individuellement parce que je suis un
collaborateur parlementaire parmi tant
d'autres mes collaborateurs des
circonscriptions ils font du travail du
travail quantifiable du travail qui
existe un comme disait une de mes
copines on n'avait pas besoin de passer
simplement au parquet financier ou
donner cinq minutes et un téléphone
portable
bonjour ma boite mail montre les envois
que j'ai pu faire et ça se trouve en
l'absence de session parlementaire à
paris thierry vient prêter main forte à
ses deux collègues en circonscription
pour son travail il touche 3000 euros
net par mois isabelle bruno la députée
ne dépense pas entièrement l'emv l'heure
du de 9600 euros qui lui est alloué et
environ 10% de cette somme reste donc
dans les caisses de l'assemblée je pense
que c'est aussi à soi même de
s'impliquer une éthique
si on a soi même pas de règle ça s'est
un peu compliqué le soir direction
argenton sur creuse où la candidate aux
législatives tient une réunion politique
pour thierry changement de casquette un
assistant parlementaire ne peut pas être
payé à faire la campagne de son député
la france c'est parce que c'est un
territoire
que j'aime les gens que j'ai appris
c'est aussi parce que c'est votre
intérêt que isabelle leblanc soirée lui
aussi quelque part oui sur évidemment si
l'entreprise continue à fonctionner oui
je serai à priori j'espère qu isabelle
mais gardera mais c'est pas sûr
[Musique]
entre commencer les impasses petra vol
international sont suspendus depuis le
24 février sur l'étang période
préélectorale
concrètement il n'y a pas de réunion
sauf quelques réunions
meeting il n'y a pas d'union travail à
la réunion od tu n'y a pas de réunion
des groupes d'amitié il n'y a pas de
réunion commission il n'y a pas de
séance publique il ya beaucoup moins de
monde
effectivement presque mortel coincé à
l'assemblée nationale nicolas martin
lalande fait le même travail que thierry
il est l'assistant parlementaire de son
père député l ère du loir et cher et
aussi le collègue de sa belle mère elle
même assistante parlementaire de son
époux j'hésitais on accepter la
proposition m'a fait mon père ou l'après
raisons tout à fait compréhensible y
compris d'ailleurs de plan de carrière
entre guillemets chez très bien que ça
peut être mal vu et que c'est même
rarement très bien vu je sais que le
travail que l'on peut faire dans ce
cadre là peut être entachée d'un soupçon
d'illégitimité ou d'incompétence ou que
sais-je donc j'ai hésité pour ces
raisons là je ne comprends parfaitement
que l'opinion publique soit choqué par
certains abus pu avoir lieu d'ailleurs
moi même j'en suis choqué et soyez en
passant ceux qui travail convenablement
en famille est effectivement en famille
sur les premières victimes de soins on y
colle a fini à 6 mentale du comique de
répétition du droit tous les jours dans
leur programme plusieurs candidats
propose l'interdiction pour les
parlementaires d'employer un membre de
leur famille comme c'est le cas pour les
députés européens ou dans les
démocraties nordique
une mesure qui ne suscite pas l'adhésion
de patrice martin-lalande non à l'idée
de réglementer de cette manière là en
interdisent encore une fois vous pourrez
envoyer votre maîtresse est pas votre
femme et c'est débile ou bien vous
pouvez employer la femme d'un autre
parlementaire et puis l'autre
parlementaire employés votre femme
voilà on a va aboutir à des années
et à des règles qui sont une autre façon
de créer des situations ambiguës
illogique je préfère un statut et le
maintien de la possibilité de la liberté
dans le parlementaire de recruter les
collaborateurs qui font le travail
les assistants parlementaires sont 2018
à l'assemblée nationale et 950 au sénat
qui a adopté des conditions de
recrutement plus restrictives leur
rémunération est en moyenne de 3350
euros brut mensuel on estime à 20% le
nombre de députés qui salarient au moins
un membre de leur famille
[Musique]
des chiffres qui semblent bien loin des
préoccupations de la vingtaine
d'étudiants en master des métiers de
l'accompagnement politique à orléans
mais le débat du jour animé par le
politologue jean garrigues est un sujet
presque philosophique
peut-on faire de la politique en étant
moralement irréprochable
c'est un peu l'hypocrisie le dire ils
sont tous pourris fait ce que finalement
on ne regarde que ça moi je pense pas
que ce soit aux politiques de change et
bien sûr il ya des choses à faire mais
c'est resté minorité je pense que c'est
surtout à cette opinion publique de
s'intéresser un peu plus qu'amicaux
scandale de chacun en fait vous parle on
parle de ceux qui ont des affaires de
ceux qui ont des raisons de se faire
enfin d'être démontrée du doigt en fait
et au final ce qui je pense en fonte
plus c'est ce dont on ne parle jamais on
en a des exemples sur un probant dans le
loiret même désaveu locaux
particulièrement tous pourris très bien
dans ce cas engagées non mais dans ce
cas là tout ce qui est dans ce cas non
mais si on suit le cliché comme ça très
bien mais dans ce cas engagez-vous et
changer les choses de l'intérieur
ce n'est pas en montrant du doigt et en
critiquant en restant passif en n'allant
pas voter qu'on va changer les choses
je pense par rapport à il ya dix ans ou
super menteur avec chirac ça fait plutôt
rire et finalement le présenter comme
sympathique
aujourd'hui ça fait plus rire il ya une
culture de cassou culture du privilège
c'est chez nous
dirigeants politiques et il faut
qu'elles évoluent est cette culture
parce qu'elle a évolué ailleurs dans les
autres pays
les grandes démocraties européennes et
ça les français ils ont déjà ils sont
déjà passés à autre chose
on voit que c'est souvent les mêmes
familles qui se régénère mais au niveau
des oncles des tantes et ça je pense que
c'est aussi important parce qu'ils sont
dans leur milieu et c'est vrai que c'est
dur d'en sortir et je pense que les
formations comme on à orléans c'est très
intéressant parce que nous on vient pas
de famille de familles ont travaillé
dans la politique et donc ça donne une
nouvelle ouverture
je crois que la sphère cahuzac ça a été
un électrochoc en 2013
beaucoup de gens ont rompu le pacte de
confiance ils ont vu qu'ils avaient un
ministre qui pouvaient mentir
effrontément devant la représentation
nationale et devant les caméras de
télévision accessoirement hélas à partir
de là ils se sont dit non ça va plus on
est dans une période de crise nous on a
du mal à boucler les fins de mois
on ne peut plus admettre ces
comportements et je crois que eux qui
sont cette jeune génération ils vont
apporter un souffle d'air pur dans cette
vie politique de futurs diplômés armée
pour exercer ces métiers aux contours
flous de l'accompagnement politique
plus étonnant nous avons découvert
qu'antoine thierry et nicolas en plus
d'être les salariés d'hommes politiques
se présentait aux prochaines
législatives où était déjà élu comme
conseiller municipaux une façon de
passer de la théorie à la réalité de
l'ombre
à la lumière
[Musique]